hey guys it's max with max tech and we
just got the brand new iPhone 10 are
here in the office so I'm excited to
check it out and answer the biggest
question that I've had about it does the
screen actually suck so I know there's
been so much controversy on this new
phone it is using an LCD display that
apples saying it's their best LCD
display which you will see but it is
just over 720p resolution which in the
end of 2018 you know going into 2018
that does sound a bit disappointing now
this is also kind of their value phone
which in reality it's still very
expensive Apple did a good job with
marketing making these thousand-dollar
phones and now a $750 phone is a value
phone but it is what it is I'm sure
they're gonna sell a ton of these as you
guys could see I do have the yellow
model this is actually gonna be for
day-to-day use for my wife so that's why
we went with yellow it really does pop
so it probably is gonna look good on
camera personally I really like the red
but it is what it is so first thing
getting out of the box it feels a little
bit thicker and I think the
specifications say it's thicker is that
right video and he actually you do feel
it kind of in the hand but it is a nice
size it actually reminds me more of the
5.8 inch version compared to my iPhone
10's max so that feels nice in the hand
of course you guys check out those
bezels I didn't think I would notice
that much of a difference but it
definitely does pop out to you if you're
used to an iPhone 10s I think Apple did
a fantastic job creating this phone
regardless of the bezels because if you
look at a lot of competition
even with OLED displays you still have
all these companies that have they have
like a big chin at the bottom their
bezels are still pretty fat and it's a
lot easier to do this kind of a design
where you have curved and with smaller
bezels with an OLED when and with an LCD
because of the backlighting is very
difficult to do this kind of design and
nobody else is doing it so props to
Apple on that all right so we're all set
up and we're on the homescreen here and
I already made a few observations which
I'll share with you in just a second but
first impressions of the display
other than those bezels of course it
still looks quite good
now if I kind of look at it I could tell
that the colors aren't as saturated they
don't
as much so it looks a little bit more
faded a little bit mermoo did on the
colors in the contrast and they're just
looking at the icons themselves they
don't look as sharp I mean you can tell
I mean I love resolution we're using a
5k iMac a 5k LG ultra fine 4k projector
so I love high resolution so looking at
this at this distance even though they
say Retina display you can't tell at a
normal distance I mean I could tell now
does it look bad or does it suck it
definitely doesn't look sucky I mean
I've looked at a lot of different
Android LCD displays and some of them
really look terrible even if they have
higher resolutions like even the 2.7 K
on an LG that I had the colors sucked
the brightness sucked even though it's
high-res it was not a great screen so I
want to go ahead and max out this
brightness here and it does get quite
bright so this is the first thing I want
to compare against the iPhone 10 so here
we are in Amazon's home screen and the
10s display the OLED is definitely
brighter we have more contrast deeper
blacks it does look better this does
definitely look like a you know a few
generations behind so let's shift it to
the side and yeah I mean we definitely
get noticeably darker kind of brighten a
shift when we go from the side where the
OLED stays almost as bright so it is an
inferior display now Apple says this is
their best LCD display so we have the
previous latest phone the iPhone 8 plus
here turned off true tone because the
color differences were apparent in
looking straight at the phones the
iPhone 10 R is brighter but interesting
Vadim over there is saying that this
screen on the iPhone 10 are off axis is
not as bright and I could see the same
thing now where the off axis performance
isn't as good maybe that has something
to do with the backlight with all these
curved edges and stuff where they can't
hide it as well so before we take a look
at some 8k footage on YouTube and
compare it to the 10s and 10's max I
want to show you something that just
jumped out to me I was trying to use a
force touch here and pressing down and
it just wouldn't go in here I was
pushing down hard whereas with the
iPhone 8 plus you guys can see you kind
of go and instantly just do a really
hard press you're in here you do a hard
press it's not doing anything so you
actually have to hold down for
or maybe about a second or so and then
you kind of get into the menu so that's
definitely something you might have to
adjust to so now let's go ahead and open
up YouTube here I have Japan and 8k
opened up and you can't actually watch
8k on your iPhone on none of these even
the ones that are higher resolution the
max you can do is 1080p so with iPhone
10s and 10's max it actually takes 1080p
and has to stretch it out a bit to fill
all the pixels on the screen whereas
with the iPhone 10 R it actually down
samples it and to the display we have
true tone on on both and the iPhone 10s
is warmer interestingly and then if you
look at off access the OLED screens
actually get a little bit bluer the the
color temperature changes whereas the
LCD doesn't the white balance stays the
same but our exposure it gets a little
darker off axis so yeah we're a little
bit sharper on the 10s but definitely
not as much of a difference as on the
home screen so if you look at the home
screen side-by-side you definitely see
the icons are much more detailed
especially we try looking up closer but
here where we're pulling 1080p on both
and down sampling it on the 10r and then
upscaling it on the 10s some of the
shots where you have really sharp edges
you can see it a little bit but they
definitely are a lot closer than I would
have expected now I really wish YouTube
were still supporting 1440p resolutions
on the iPhone app here in the night
shots right here oh my goodness that's
that's a good display different so here
and the 10 are the black looks great
we're on the 10s it is pure pure black
and it definitely looks a lot better
yeah we do have a little bit more detail
but I'm looking up close here so I think
if you're gonna be watching YouTube
videos honestly you're not gonna suffer
very much with this display overall does
this display suck no I don't think it
sucks I think most people are gonna be
very happy with it the bezels do
definitely jump out at you especially if
you are used to an iPhone 10s or you
know a 10s Max or iPhone 10 going from
this guy right here the bezels look
different just because they're dark and
they're a little bit thicker on the
edges as well but I think with the
larger screen size and it filling up the
whole display you're not gonna be that
disap
now one other thing that I noticed is on
the iPhone 10 s it's like more slick on
the screen I don't know if it's the
coating they're using but it just feels
a lot slicker there's a lot less
resistance wear on the iPhone 10 R it
just feels like there's a little bit
more resistance little bit more drag so
holding him side by side the last kind
of opinion I want to share is this
definitely does feel more premium it's
definitely has something to do with the
stainless steel it feels really nice
really smooth it has a little bit more
weight to it even though it's a smaller
size and here it just feels kind of like
a matte finish like an iPhone like a
standard iPhone 8 or iPhone 7 so
definitely not as premium feeling but
for the price point with that - a 12
processor and having the same wide-angle
camera on here I think this thing is
gonna sell really really well there's a
lot of people that want to upgrade from
the iPhone 6 7 8 to one of these so I'm
gonna be doing a lot more tests with
this I'm gonna actually switch to the
iPhone 10 R for a week after using the
10 and 10 s for over a year now and I'll
kind of share my experiences with you
guys to make sure you guys are
subscribed make sure you guys have those
notifications enable so you guys don't
miss out on that and maybe we'll do some
camera comparisons as well this been max
max tech and I'll see you in the next
video